hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots so here's a little
clip of
uh Bobby Lee and Burke Cher do you want
to set this one up Virgie or do we just
play it uh it it happens pretty fast I
don't think it needs to set up okay so
here we go artists
what do you mean like we're okay let me
go back for a second so you get you have
to get just a little
bit of what bur Cher thinks of himself
you ready oh
God when you see
artists what do you mean like we're
different people like we wouldn't work
in a night yeah but what I'm saying is
that
e they're built different bro oh my God
this is the same as [__] Kurt meter's
the civilian line yeah honestly I could
never do what you pieces of [__] do to
to scrape by I don't know how you do it
the [__] up there are people that I know
that work a [__] nine-to-five job or
[__] are bartenders that are funnier
than you've ever been so shut up cuz
people call me an artist and in my mind
I'm like is it art you no no and this
isn't art either by the way no what you
do
yes
why do you think that of yourself
because he thinks he's cool it's art to
take your shirt off and be fat it's like
a performance I'm [__]
Picasso performance yeah art maybe you
overshare I do but that's like oh so
what I'm saying is is podcasting in art
I don't think it is oh I think no no as
somebody who makes their money primarily
from P it's it's it's it's show it's fun
but but I wouldn't consider this art no
it's an entertainment product
entertainment product thank you it is I
well I know radio is an art and what we
do is a version of radio it's just a
little more open and free and there are
people that R is not radio is not art no
radio is also an entertainment product
like virie
said are not are not as free
individually like I have a bunch of
friends I'm hanging out with next
weekend in Tampa that would never in a
million years share the way we share and
and that and listen to this I'm meeting
with people that just aren't like us man
like artists like you know they share we
share man Hey listen here all of you
[__] comedians now all right I
remember when merch and I first started
doing this and MCH you'll remember this
you know you remember this msh when
merch and I very old olden days we were
comedians weren't doing podcasts
podcasters are doing podcasts
right I remember comedians making fun of
podcast do you remember that MCH
comedians were like oh you're just a
podcaster what are you now every one of
these
[__] every one of these [__] has a
podcast now they think they're [__]
podcast no you're not you you know what
you are you're doing a Long Live read
for your next set of gigs okay stop it
this is not art it's fun it's a great
way to make a living and yeah man I love
doing it but like I would never call
myself an artist mostly because I'm not
a [__]
Ence allows someone listening right now
to go if this is artwork the machine is
a crayon
drawing that wouldn't even be put on a
fridge now now Taylor swifted an omelet
bar that's art let me tell you something
let's talk about art for a second here
let's talk about art that's art this is
artwork okay this is
artwork this is artwork thinking about
getting them framed yeah belongs in the
move
mhm so wait I I feel normal and so
whatever that is whether it's a book or
an actor playing a role or or an uh an
author or a director that allows you to
feel let me let let me explain something
to
you to be a good I'm not going to speak
to Comic because I've never been a
standup comic but to be a good podcaster
or good broadcaster or any doing
this you have to Hate Yourself and you
can't have this high of an opinion of
yourself or your show's not good right
am I right like anybody who thinks
they're this a good at it I'm so good at
podcasting never has a good
podcast never never never has a good
podcast
no connect a connection to humanity and
so I I sometimes I feel bad about my
oversharing but I know there's people
that go hey I deal with the anxiety too
I didn't even know I was talking about
my anxiety or my OCD or the like and I
regret it like there's times I've shared
recently a couple times that I you know
that there after I fell off a waterfall
I had a problem with pills and Leanne
helped me get out of it and I regret
ever sharing that because I know that
the internet sometimes highlights that
and goes look at this drug ad out of
[__]
touch you heard that right he wrote he
flew on a private jet to go be at a
waterfall and he's sad that he had to
share that that he got addicted to
pills he's an artist man
he's basically the Andy Warhol of our
die yeah we're lucky to have this guy to
be alive at the same time as the great
artist Bert
ker of the machine piece of [__] he is a
machine fan he really thinks who the
[__] he is huh it's so off-putting and
these people don't hear themselves these
people do not hear themselves I'm
certain that if Da Vinci was alive today
he too would have a podcast we we got to
make we we we got to we got to make
comics hate themselves again Comics have
been too [__] liking themselves too
much lately it's not good for [__]
comedy right yeah you know yeah why do
you think the best Comics are dead they
all started getting real Brazen once
[__] Mike David went and hid by his
pay
wall [__]
Christ no man it was a period of my life
two periods really Xanax and oxies but
this but I want to bring something up
and I've never I had never thought I
would
okay this is why I love you yeah yeah
and I just I just want to okay and I
don't want you to be offended by what
I'm bringing up okay do you realize how
hard it is to offend me he's not like
other guys no he's different not like
all the other guys here let me try to
offend you go look at the Ron Tomato
score for your
movie yeah that didn't do how about the
box office I know hey but your friends
are Mark Hamill now that's cool it's
personal all right okay
okay
so let me ask you a direct question all
right okay do you think you're an
alcoholic can we answer that for
him do you want to phone a friend yeah
do me a favor phone Tom sagora see what
he says the answer you're looking for is
yes no okay no he does not but you but
you admitted to be addicted to pills and
stuff look at your skin tone dog but you
drink a lot no I yeah I do you have yeah
I have and IA and I do okay so there you
I have and I do man I used to do drugs I
still do but I used to too and you know
what [__] Mitch hedri Mitch HED hated
himself enough to kill himself with
drugs that's why he was such a good
comedian yep because to me good one from
him was I don't do drugs anymore but I
also don't do them any less
yeah
um maybe you're not I don't know right
but there are when I look at you
sometimes I go he
alcoholic yeah I think he's an alcoholic
and it's like so you think that um you
don't ever ever want you don't ever
think you problem Bobby Lee intervention
is just him [__] footing around the
topic for [__] 10 minutes and pry
great it's pretty great and you want to
get sober no good interesting yeah very
interesting no I know listen to this all
of these [__] [__] West Coast [__]
therapy [__] have been going to therapy
so much that you hear you hear them
using the therapy talk that they heard
right interesting wow it's so interest
because now we've gotten we've got we've
we've gone so deep into the gay [__]
therapy West Coast talk comedy talk that
these podcasts are turning into the
other comedians doing therapy sessions
with other
comedians which is really fun it's
exciting it's really funny stuff
it's art yeah I mean like watch how easy
this is hey merch you an
alcoholic yeah you want to get sober
no bud all right there you go see that
was easy Bert do you ever think you're
an artist though no what a what about a
Sandwich Artist at Subway are you a
sandwich artist
uh was pretty good at when I worked at
the deli I wouldn't say I was an artist
though uh Tom roll Mercedes boys if you
don't mind them slightly stale I can get
you a case of whatever chips you like
any idea I mean MCH really likes
Pringles um look I'll say this like
Barista espresso art is more art than
what B when they do like a little face
or like a heart or a little cat yeah
it's pretty cool they do little ears
with the little foam sticking up yeah
yeah I'd rather watch that than the
machine on the John but merch honestly
I'm not going to lie I've never gotten
like a coffee or an espresso with the
little foam at the top with some art and
not and kind of impressed like that does
always get an extra tip out I'll be like
all right it's pretty [__] cool when
I make a little face in it like all
right hey there's an extra five I was
pretty
tight